hello and welcome to 0 plane ketron and
let's see answer soft spot in this very
sketchy banco repertoire and playing
yeah yeah maybe I have just playable
only now would be five i keep getting
killed which is probably very much
justified because i don't know where to
tell all that well hmm no b5 is a little
bit of a strange strange banco version
but can it be all that bad we'll see
probably so we took there yeah I cannot
get to this some fashionable line down
with the with Queenie five but it's
still going to be playable yeah I once
saw this line with this quick night come
night move him I think it's supposed to
be directed against the rupee 19 but
don't ask me why I now we'll see what
happens it's a little bit shaky or a
little bit dicey to play this opening
against a strong player without knowing
it so we'll see yeah really one now that
okay well he's not going to play quick
be three year this is sam an upside of
this early night maneuver okay here here
he may be can't know we can cannot defy
was hanging so I'm canceling him how
could you one no be three might be
possible ok so I really have no idea
this is played if I go nite c4b 3385 is
that possible yes night a four day and
should be 5 i'm sure but ok i cannot
reinvent how I invent everything he had
just have to go with it
[Music]
and night a for Bishop b5 was my idea
and if he takes I think I should be ok
so here we go not much of an alternative
and going back that would be Bishop t2
it would be embarrassing for the Queen
so my idea is to take on a for Queen
takes but should be five and then grab a
2 so this is the idea ok it's an
interesting move so what's going on but
I can take here right and then Queen a
six that's not bad now a4 is hanging and
e2 is hanging as well so grab this now
only too I can also take on c3 you're
just not necessarily that bad but ok I
take on etool Knight takes Queen tags
look you one Queen a sixth rupee 795 not
quite sure not quite sure probably after
so step in it's a different move Queen
86 no Queen 86 looks it looks very
logical in fact I can also take a two
now by the way that could be possible
just queen 82 we need to look at two we
wrote this seven
rooty tooty 654 it cannot be bad but
this also shouldn't be all that terrible
his rook is somewhat strapped
yeah this rock is somewhat trap and
still that what I mean okay Kenny okay
can go to c7 but still Bishop f6 looks
like it wins the look let's see how we
save that with Roxy six at the end okay
that's the thing with rocks is sex yeah
it's definitely possible 6 yeah
Bishopville come to the five
yeah okay it's not ideal mate doesn't
have to take yet this is the thing you
might keep control will over Wow ok
[Music]
certainly be time morning threatening be
five
[Music]
who came
da fam always under pressure here I can
still pre would
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's not so easy now for him as well I
think not sure about threatening Bishop
e7 there might be tactics with a six and
so on okay at least he's still using
time
[Music]
check check check it's not going to be
win check check check game draw okay no
time and makes it difficult um they're
very tough very tough game and
interesting very interesting
complications if we start looking here
he went 92 okay the engine just wants to
go back actually it's actually
interesting move was when I it's a good
move he has to take now more or less and
now okay he has those two pawns hanging
yeah and fine and I'm winning upon him
and if I get one back I think my
position should be good well that's good
no I didn't see that i just i just
calculated this and felt it should be
okay and it probably is kind of
so I saw this line back you took it yeah
now of course I can take on 82 when it's
a line that I mentioned but I felt like
I cannot win hear anything thought I saw
this and ok I'm ok here but I thought I
cannot win even though I'm active the
engine loves my position and maybe I
should have gone for that it's not for
stem it's not forced the engine once you
don't go here and then 95 I think this
position I would have lied I've got 93
may be coming and so on it's cannot be
bad ok this was interesting he just yeah
that is rook trapped in a way but this
is of course very strong compensation
with Roxy 6 here maybe I should have
avoided that somehow but ok I mean going
to be realistic it's a blitz game so
this and now before plus I'll heavy
pressure so I recited to remove this and
now a 5 yeah this seems to give it away
according to the engine takes takes and
then Queenie force wonder what stockfish
give Sam and this looks very strong it
looks at the rook I cannot take here
because of the shack fork and I don't
have a good novia now that would be very
strong a fine ok oh this actually also
reduces to 2 ticks and create form so
Queen a 6 was better it's not a very
intuitive move may have it ok intuitive
or not this is just they just move by
move one side this is what the engine
wants to do actually
and then it evaluates this as equal as
the kind of thing that can be usually
irritating in blitz for human but
Queenie for saves the day again with
this trick ok so here here Queenie for
would have killed me and the beat xe5
also seems to be very strong I just
wanted to take what's the deal here I
can take on c5 and that's very sad can
do this and then promote and no it
didn't didn't didn't see that one so
then here we are talking about a draw
[Music]
yeah I thought a six withdraw I was a
bit surprised because here this this
makes it makes it a draw I have to take
care of the a gay porn and check here we
are in a complete draw yeah this is just
maybe losing that check ok I actually
have more time at this point this moment
check yeah yeah the Queen trade is
probably not great Queen D sagginess
what the engine wants to do and then
there's a of what I've in the corner I
win the pawn okay check he sped up
enormously waited to went
of course I wasn't winning but check in
some check this time and stack crapshoot
can be happy to eliminate the porn as
happy that I don't lose okay well I hope
you enjoyed it to the good fight thanks
for watching